[Music]
come on I've been waiting all night for
this Rachel hold on one sec go on Katie
see let's see see
come on baby come on come it's going to
get there it's a it's aut here's the
thing Nikki hay is hoping she's not put
bumpers in they got to put the bumpers
in the
gutters right people it's January 16th
2024 I'm Dave Ruben this is the Ruben
report we're live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and locals postgame show Ruben
report. locals.com and yes the Iowa
caucus was yesterday it did not go the
way I wish it would have gone you win
some and you lose some in politics we're
going to unpack all of that and uh I
think you will see that I will
consistently try to do exactly what I've
been doing which is just tell you what I
think about things and and then let the
chips fall where they may but it is I
would say fairly obvious right now that
all of the momentum is in Trump's Corner
uh we'll pull out some of the numbers
we'll get into some of the speeches and
all that stuff and then what I really
want to do with today's show is figure
out how we can focus whether you were
for Des santis in this thing or even if
you're for Nikki Haley or obviously the
bulk of Iowans who were for Donald Trump
we're all roughly on the same team right
we all roughly do want a border we all
roughly do want uh capitalism to to
remain our economic system uh there are
basic things we think that the country
that the United States of America is
fundamentally good and our founding was
good uh and I think there are a lot of
ways we can come together all the the
slings and the arrows and the nastiness
and the owning and the fighting and the
destroying like that's all part of
primary politics uh but there is a way
bigger enemy here right there absolutely
is and I would be saying that even if
Dan santis crushed it last night there's
a way bigger enemy here the enemy if
you're a disantis guy really isn't Trump
and the enemy if you're a trump guy
really isn't disantis or any other
extrapolation of anyone on the
Republican side Vivic or uh or Nikki uh
the the enemy is the Communists are the
Communists the enemy are the marxists
the collectivists largely the radicals
who've taken over the Democrat Party the
globalists all of that stuff and I think
that right now if it is going to be
Trump as the nominee the best thing that
I can do and anyone who's sort of on the
fence or maybe was a trump supporter not
as into him anymore or maybe is going to
go all right I've never even voted
Republican for before but I see what's
going on on the left so I've got to vote
for Trump but I'm not so thrilled like
the best thing that we can do is push
him maybe to be a little bit better than
he has been uh if we uphold some honesty
some Integrity uh some intolerance of
the Endless nonsense and the owning of
everybody I think maybe that's how our
voice can be heard that that's at least
an approach that I'm going to try to
take I want to start actually uh by not
diving right into what happened in Iowa
last night but a story that I heard on
Twitter a couple days ago from new
Argentinian president Javier Malay uh
this is going to be in Spanish so if
you're listening on audio only uh we're
going to have some T subtitles obviously
I'll try to recap it afterwards uh but
here's a little parable about a donkey
and the well take a
listen
[Music]
foree
okay the short of it for those of you
that uh are listening on audio only as a
man has a donkey he falls into the well
the guy's like all right there's nothing
I can do I can't pull you out of the
well so he starts burying the donkey
alive the donkey is like what do you
mean I've done all this stuff for you
all of these years and everyone else
jumps in and they're just going to bury
the donkey alive and then as they're
throwing dirt into the ditch the donkey
realizes oh now there's more dirt in the
ditch I can get out of the ditch I will
be back I will come back and what Malay
is saying there is I'm the donkey you
the media have tried to pile on me the
globalism trial to pile on me but I'm
here and I'm going to fight and I think
that that's a little bit of kind of
where Donald Trump's at right now but I
also think it's a little bit where all
of us should be right now the entire
machine has lied to us through all
through for so many years at this point
and through so many stories right covid
Russia collusion the whole damn thing uh
that it is time that maybe we got
focused again and we and we had a little
hope a little optimism a little for
fortitude and uh and got to the Future
so okay there's a little story of a
donkey and O uh but now let's get to
what happened uh yesterday here of
course are the results of last night
this is from The New York Times uh it
was actually quite a low turnout which
some people did expect because the
weather was absolutely freezing so only
a little over a 100,000 people actually
voted in the caucuses usually about
200,000 people vote and Trump did get
51% of that so you he's going to get 20
delegates DeSantis did overperform in
that he was lower than 20% in the polls
he was at like 12 or 133% and he ended
up with 21% so he gets eight delegates
uh Nikki was right after that with 19%
seven delegates Vivic who immediately
dropped out after uh got three delegates
and then I don't know who Ryan
blinklebee I'm Ryan anyone want to vote
for me he got s so good for Ryan um I'll
give you more of my thoughts on this in
just a second but Ben Shapiro did a
little selfie video last night that I
kind of thought summed up the reality of
the situation quite well here is the
very quick story Donald Trump wins
walking away all of the pollsters called
this thing pretty much as soon as the
polls open that raises questions in and
of itself about procedure about whether
that affects the final vote tally but
bottom line is they were doing that
based on the entrance polling data
Donald Trump is way out ahead Donald
Trump is so far out ahead that the rest
of the field can't even see him this is
Secretariat against the rest of the
field in the 1973 Belmont Stakes what
does that mean going forward it means
that de facto Trump is the nominee if no
one could challenge him in Iowa if
nobody really has a chance of
challenging him based on that momentum
going into New Hampshire if nobody has a
challenge for him in South Carolina then
all you can say at this point is that he
is preparing for the general election
against Joe Biden and we're already
there maybe it was always going to be
this way after all he's been treated by
the Republican electorate as the
incumbent president and he's been
treated that way because that's how they
think of him many Republicans think by
the way that he won the last election
against Joe Biden rightly or wrongly and
so why wouldn't they treat him that way
there might have been a brief moment in
time where there were Minds that were
open to be changed enough to possibly
challenge Trump but that time passed a
while ago and it's pretty obvious at
this point that Donald Trump is going to
be your Republican nominee in 2024 all
right that's Ben Shapiro being Ben
Shapiro a lot of sense uh the line that
I want to focus on maybe it was always
going to be this way that might be right
right and I never denied that here but I
think fighting the good F and doing it
honestly and uh and forthrightly is
always worth it right like clearly I
thought and I still believe that Ronda
santis because of age because of policy
because of the picking the correct
fights and all of those things was the
guy for this moment but I'm not the king
of the world right so the the caucus
goers of Iowa disagreed with that that's
just fine now I can either just fight
and swim upstream and demand the world
uh acquest to me
uh or I can see the world as it is as we
talked about yesterday and I think Ben
is completely right like we know
DeSantis isn't going to do particularly
well in New Hampshire that sort of looks
like it'll be Haley's last stop and then
and then there's South Carolina but but
Trump trump has this so again I think
the best thing that we can do but that
doesn't mean it's not worth fighting the
good fight I I just want to as a sidebar
for just a second um I voted for Trump
last time he lost it was worth fighting
for him I fought very hard for him and
he lost I think it was the right thing
to do uh just two years ago I fought
very hard for the recall of Gavin Nome
and to get Larry Elder elected the
governor of California we lost but it
was worth doing like the fight fighting
for what you believe in if you do it
honestly is always worth it it doesn't
mean you're always going to win most
people in politics don't win all the
time right so whether it was the recall
election of 21 I fought for disantis in
Florida he crushed it last year right
now I think we just have to get on board
with Trump like it's just kind of how we
have to do it but and this really is
going to be my focus as I just said to
you guys what I am going to do and I'm
going to try to do really really it's
going to be quite a thread to to have to
get through that needle uh is push him
to be a little bit better than his
instincts might right it's not I'm not
going to do this out of worship I'm
going to do this out of pushing him to
be honest as honest as possible to have
integrity and so that we can get back to
something of an America that we all love
so that we can actually make America
great again I think that's the only way
we actually win right otherwise we just
get more drama and the rest of it so the
data look I just can't deny the data I
can't deny the data the data is telling
us that whether you like it or not Trump
is our guy uh and I want to get to his
victory speech I think there were some
nice moments in it and some silliness
and everything else but before we do
that let me talk to you guys about TWC
Health all right so I've been talking to
you about the wellness company and their
medical emergency kit for a while now
and their next product is one that I
believe every American should be taking
regularly or at the very least have on
hand for when necessary it's called
Spike support and you're going to want
to listen up if you're not thinking that
something is going on at this point with
so many previously healthy people exping
myocarditis blood blood clots turbo
cancers menstrual irregularities
miscarriages and the new died suddenly
phenomenon uh you're not paying
attention the culprit is Spike protein
Spike protein is a lingering threat from
both the vaccine and the man-made virus
links to all kinds of long-term health
issues even fizer is now admitting there
are quote problems so many people myself
included are looking for answers and
ways to stay healthy despite the spike
proteins that are part of our population
now and while we know the answers won't
ever come from mainstream sources truth
seeking doctors like Dr Peter McCulla Dr
Drew Pinsky my buddy and their team at
wellness company are here to provide
answers and hope there's one question
that these doctors get asked every
single day how do I detox from the spike
protein Left Behind from the vaccine in
covid and thanks to the wellness company
there's actually something we can do
Spike support formula is a unique blend
of natural ingredients aims to block and
dissolve Spike protein in your body so
you can get back to that pre-o feeling
and stop waiting for the other shoe to
drop their website has tons of
testimonials from customers reporting
increased mental Clarity and energy
levels amongst other things whether they
got poked or not reclaim your health
with T at TWC doal / rubben use code
ruin for 15% off at checkout tww c.
rubben code Rubin in this fight for
truth and medical Freedom you owe it to
yourself and your family to take control
of your health and now back to me okay
so as I said and we all know and I'm
very happy that I assume soon enough we
will have our governor back here in
Florida and we're going to strengthen
this great Free State uh but Trump won
last night he is going to be the nominee
I don't really see any way around it
there's no sense of me bullshitting you
now I probably you know I've had a lot
of trump people pissed at me over the
last year now I probably have some
hardcore disantis people pissed at me
but I but I have to just tell you what I
think it's as simple is that here is
some of Trump's uh acceptance speech wi
it well not acceptance he didn't accept
anything here is his uh hey I won
tonight's speech well I want to thank
everybody this has been some period of
time and most importantly we want to
thank the great people of Iowa thank you
we love you all what a turnout what a
crowd and I really think this is time
now for everybody our country to come
together we want to come together uh
whether it's republican or democrat or
liberal or conservative it would be so
nice if we could come together and
straighten out the world and straighten
out the problems and straighten out all
of the death and destruction that we're
witnessing that's practically never been
like this it's just so important and I
want to make that a very big part of our
message we're going to come together
it's going to happen happen soon too
going to happen
soon okay I don't know if we're going to
come together Democrat and Republican
come together liberal and conservative
come together uh but those of us who
lean right let's say or Centrist to a
bit right we should come together right
now and I think if if he goes with that
message right and now tries to fill in
the pieces okay okay Ron yeah I kind of
lied about Co in Florida and yeah you
had nothing to do with Soros or Paul ran
or whatever like we'll bring you back
into the fold and be you know I hit you
at the end there but you know you're
young and you've got something then we
can start building a coalition that will
make sense I don't think we're going to
have like like sort of this like um
shangrala of peace right like I don't
think we're just going to be like all
the Democrats are gonna be like oh
Donald Trump's saying nice things this
is all wonderful like maybe you say
Nikki you know what you're not a bird
brain I I mean I think it's very likely
he will end up choosing her as VP but we
could get some roughly United group of
people that believe in freedom and
liberty together right now and then
again the challenge for some of us that
were en thrilled with Trump this whole
time will be to push him in the right
way not to bow not to bow I have no
intentions of doing that uh but if we're
just like all right he is the guy the
reason I supported him last time around
after not supporting him the first time
is because he became a good president he
was Sid track by Co and he screwed up a
whole bunch of stuff but we all know the
country was in better shape and the
world was in better shape while he was
President uh so I think his speech right
there the Come Together part which was
the that was the main heart of the
speech I think was a pretty good
indicator hopefully of what a campaign
might look like he did thank Rod de
santis and Nikki Haley with a little bit
of Trump's classic humor the Senators
the congressmen from Washington they
came down from all different states I
want to thank you very much I want to
congratulate Ron and Nikki for having uh
a good a good time together we're all
having a good time
together and uh I think they both
actually did very well I really do I
think they both did very well all right
actually they both did do kind of well
right they both got around 20% the
Santa's a little over Nikki a little bit
under so that means that if you were to
add Nikki and the santis together that's
around 40% you throw and v 7 that's 47%
voted against Trump but again it just
doesn't matter he got the the 51% or
whatever it was um so okay that's Trump
little humor you can see he's trying to
bring the fold together right now and I
just I think that's important right I'm
not I'm not blowing smoke up your ass
it's like I can I can just sit here and
tell you like Ron's gonna win New
Hampshire and Ron's gonna and it's just
like probably ain't going to happen look
anything can happen at this point you
never know but like it probably ain't uh
anyway here is Trump saying a little bit
he didn't get too far into what his
plans would be uh but a bit about how we
can rebuild some of our crumbling
infrastructure in DC and in our
cities we want a country of Law and
Order so we're going to rebuild the
capital of our country Washington DC
we're going to scrub those beautiful
marble columns and get the swas stickers
off them and we're going to scrub them
and get the graffiti off them and we're
going to clean the streets and we're
going to re build the
streets and we're not going to have
rusted
medians through the middle that are
falling down into the roads where
foreign dignitaries from all over the
world come and they look and we're not
going to be riding on top of garbage
like I did just a month ago riding on
top of garbage we're going to rebuild
our beautiful Washington DC and we're
going to take control of it and we're
going to make unbelievably harsh
penalties for people that go around
shooting last week they shot three
people and every night something happens
it's uh it's so sad and likewise we're
going to rebuild our cities and we'll
work with the Democrats to do it I'd be
glad to work with the people in New York
we're going to work with the people in
Chicago and La we're going to rebuild
our cities and we're going to have to
deport we're going to have to have a
deportation level that we haven't seen
in this country for a long time since
Dwight Eisenhower
actually all right so like it it yes he
speaks and look kind of crazy way but
like directionally he's right about all
of these things how about we fix our fix
our crumbling cities how about we deal
with the crime and the shooting how
about we Deport people who are here and
we don't know what they believe or how
they got here or what their intentions
are like again that is all correct and
that is all stuff that Ronda santis
believes certainly now you can say maybe
Trump can't do it the swamps e them
alive we shouldn't be rebuilding DC we
should be dispersing the power
structures of DC throughout the all all
of that stuff can be debated uh but all
of that being said that's not really the
the Enemy at the moment the Enemy at the
moment is this Administration that has
ushered in in essence as I said at the
top of the show communism Marxism
collectivism Biden e Biden omics uh Dei
all of those things so here is Trump
then going after Biden so I don't want
to be overly uh rough on the president
but I have to say that he is the worst
president that we've had in the history
of our country he's destroying our
country all right that's pretty good
right like that's pretty that's the
Trump everybody loves I don't want to be
over layer on the guy he's the worst
mother yes okay and and that really at
least in modern times that is true and
no one with their head on straight
believes that Joe Biden is actually
running the show or anything else and
now we will see uh if the if the
Democrats just push Biden out of the way
or if he falls up the stairs or whatever
else it might be so I want to shift for
a
moment from the the racehorse politics
part of this and some people like the
santis and some people like Trump and
okay can we pull this thing all together
uh to the media's coverage of this
because largely what created Donald
Trump in the first place is there was a
media that was lying to us about
everything and Not only was it lying to
us about everything if you questioned it
as you guys know it called you a racist
and a bigot and everything
and it seems like it is just going to
continually go down that path so as
Donald Trump was giving his speech last
night uh CNN actually cut away from the
speech and uh well listen to Jake Tapper
we're going to seal up the
Border because right now we have an
invasion we have an invasion of millions
and millions of people that are coming
into our country I can't imagine why
they think that's a good thing Donald
Trump declaring Victory with a
historically strong showing in the Iowa
caucuses if these numbers hold the
biggest victory for a non-incumbent
president in the modern era for this
contest a relatively subdued speech as
these things go so far although here he
is right now under under my voice you
hear him repeating his anti-immigrant
rhetoric you got it at the end there so
they cut away from the speech now you
can argue they shouldn't cut away from
speeches or they should every Network
makes a decision you know sometimes if
they're all showing the exact same
things one network might want to cut
away so that you'll watch something
different on their Network right you'll
watch analysis on their Network while 10
other networks are just showing the same
speech it was the end line there right
we're cutting away and under under my
voice his anti-immigration rhetoric um
it's not anti-immigration to have a
border that is what put Donald Trump in
the White House the first time right I'm
going to build a wall and make Mexico
pay for it now that turned out he
admitted that was a lie he didn't get
much of the wall built okay fine
but that that notion right that we have
a country or we don't that is what
pushed him into the White House when you
guys said it could never happen and here
you are doing it again it is not
anti-immigration to have a border it is
anti- illegal immigration to have a
border right to talk about an invasion
what else can you call it when we see
these thousands and thousands of people
just wandering into our country it is an
invasion so I just have no doubt that
unfortunately the media much like the
left no matter how many things they get
wrong instead of ever having a
self-reflective moment Tapper might be
like you know maybe I should think about
this a little bit different because I
don't want Donald Trump as president
again no they are just going to double
down and double down and double down and
by the way of course it is not just CNN
doing it here is Rachel mattow on
MSNBC interject I'm sorry I just have to
do a little bit of business just for a
second um at this point in the evening
the projected winner of the Iowa
caucuses um has just started giving his
victory speech uh we will keep an eye on
that as it happens uh we will let you
know if there's any news made in that
speech if there's anything noteworthy
something substantive and important um
the reason I'm saying this is of course
there is a reason that we and other news
organizations have generally stopped
giving an unfiltered live platform to
remarks by former president trump it is
not out of spite it is not a decision
that we relish it is a decision that we
regularly
revisit um and honestly earnestly it is
not an easy decision but there is a cost
to us as a news organization of
knowingly broadcasting untrue things
that is a fundamental truth of our
business and who we are and so his
remarks tonight will not air here live
we will monitor them um and let you know
about any news that he that's so
incredible she will not knowingly
broadcast untrue things this is a woman
who puts up all of the progressives to
lie about everything all the time she
lied about vaccines we've played all of
the clips of her getting everything
wrong they they have no problem having
former employees of Joe Biden Jens saki
interview Joe Biden on their Network to
promote his lies like okay they just
like lies one way but again I'm I'm I
know that's not you're not going oh my
God I can't believe that happened I'm
just trying to show you they are going
to do the exact damn thing that they did
last time whether it is CNN or MSNBC and
it's like it's also I know you're not an
MSNBC viewer if you're watching this but
the way they treat them like children we
can't show you what he's actually saying
if we deem it okay once once we go
through it you know we're going to flip
through the papers and who we'll check
what you can see and then we'll let you
see it afterward it's like who wants to
be pandered to that way I guess we know
who well it's actually not that many
people because their ratings aren't so
great anyway I was very excited about
this clip because we have not shown you
a clip of Joy Reed in quite some time I
don't know what happened to her we used
to make fun of Joy Reed all the time
she's back her hair is blonder than ever
which I'm pretty sure is cultural
appropriation but I guess she's allowed
to do it and you're not going to believe
what she's blaming Donald Trump's win on
well Nikki would have done better but
you know racist new hampsh I think the
point that you made step I mean it's the
elephant in the room she's still a brown
lady that's got to try to win in a part
party that is deeply anti-immigrant and
which accepts the notion that you can
say immigrants are poisoning the blood
of our country she's getting you know
birther by Donald Trump um and I don't
care how much the Don class likes her
which will ramp up a lot the better she
does in New Hampshire so it's still a
challenge I don't see how she becomes
the nominee of that party with Donald
Trump still around I can't picture it
happening maybe it could happen Ronda
sanz's only argument for staying in it
is he's the white guy that he can still
make the appeal to White EV while we
it's it's so evil what they do and again
I'm just showing this to show you
they're they're they are literally
putting it in our faces on night one of
any votes being cast in a primary we did
it exactly this way last time we're
going to do it exactly this way this
time like it's the same freaking script
as if they yes Ronda santz is only
staying in because he's a white guy and
Donald Trump Donald Trump barely said
anything about Nikki Haley he called her
bird brain Nikki Haley didn't win
because there isn't a cohesive set of
views that she has that works for
conservatives in a Republican primary
that's why she didn't win I don't I
literally don't know one person I did
and I'm and I'm a pretty online guy I
didn't see one person going after Nikki
Haley because of her ethnicity or
because she's not white it's just pure
nonsense like absolutely pure nonsense
but that's all Joy Reed's got so as long
as we brought Joy Reed back on the
program let's give her a second clip I
feel like the important sort of data
point and you know Steve talks about it
a lot he's he's going to probably talk
about a little more tonight is that the
these are white Christians that this is
a state that is over represent over
represented by white Christians that are
going to participate in these caucuses
especially tonight um I today earlier
today reached out to Robert Jones Robbie
Jones um from the public religion
Research Institute knowing that we were
going to talk about Iowa and this is a
hyper Evangelical white State and he
said the following to me Iowa is about
61 % white Christian the country as a
whole is approximately 41% white
Christian and in Iowa we're talking
about Evangelical white
chrisan we brought her back what can I
tell you um there's no Iowa is not over
represented by white Christians white
Christians might happen to live in Iowa
but that's okay uh White Christians are
allowed to live in certain places Jews
are allowed to live in certain places
Muslims are allowed to live in certain
places imagine if if the results of an
election didn't go the way she wanted
and then she got on air and was like
Dearborn Michigan is is over represented
by Brown Muslims or imagine if Sean
Hannity said that on Fox like what all
hell would be breaking loose but these
people are allowed to be subtly racist
constantly always against white people
which again between that and the Border
was the thing that drove trump it was
the rocket fuel that drove Trump the
first time and these dingbats are going
to do it again right in front of our
faces and and that blond hair on that
woman that is not natural I'm not I'm
not you know a hair color expert but
something's not right there anyway look
they got away with all of this
racialization with cancel culture and
everything else during the Trump era and
they're bringing it back right in our
faces right now and they would have done
it to anyone right like I how many times
did I say to you even if the Santa had
won last night they'd be doing the exact
same thing they would be saying oh my
God he's Trump with a he's Hitler with a
calculator he's even worse so you you
get what the script is
um but they're going to do it again and
now here is where I want to shift a
little bit towards how we can all push
Trump in a better Direction I do not
think that just telling Trump you did
everything right and you're you're
perfect and you're you're God and you're
our orange golden calf uh is the way to
do this I think that the best thing we
can do is say to Trump there are some
things you screwed up when you were
president there are some things you
screwed up as a candidate and if we if
we nudge him in the right way I think
the the good thing about Trump is that
he is able to hear those things and
adjust accordingly right like when you
look at Trump he isn't uh for all his
flaws and all the craziness and all my
frustrations with him he isn't like so
rigid in his ideology that he can't
shift a little bit so I think it is
important that if we if we go back and
we point out to him here are some of the
mistakes along the way let's be a little
bit better right now imagine if he level
up but if we just worship Him He will
not level up so let's let's go back uh
just a little bit well first let's go
back to the thing that we're fighting
the most right because the thing that
we're fighting the most uh is is Joe
Biden and the craziness so uh let's go
back to the type of weaponization of
government and the way that these people
have tried to control every bit of your
lives you may remember this one from
January of
2021 with Co cases surging and deaths
now five times higher than just a month
ago President Biden is requiring tens of
millions more Americans to get
vaccinated we've been patient but our
patience is wearing
thin and your refusal has cost all of us
this is not about Freedom or personal
choice it's about protecting yourself
and those around you employees who
refuse could be punished even fired if
you want to work with the federal
government and do business to this get
vaccinated and by the way
show some
respect awful it's worse every I know
we've showed you that clip before but
it's worse every time as time goes by as
time goes by it gets even worse so that
is the inclination that is the uh that
is the ethos of what we are fighting
these people who want to control you
right who wanted to inject you and
wanted to make sure you had to stay home
and we know whatever it is whether the
next thing's covid or whatever like the
people whose inclination is we are the
government and you better freaking obey
us that's a problem right and what's
another problem with these people before
I get to how we can nudge Trump in a
positive way another problem with these
people is that they use the levers of
government to quite literally remove
their opposition from the ballots and to
put their political opponents in jail
Trump's not thrilled with that I think
it's very unfair when a opponent a
political opponent is prosecuted by the
doj by Biden's doj uh so they're losing
in every poll they're losing in almost
every
demographic uh numbers came out today
that are uh really very mindboggling if
you happen to be Joe Biden and I think
they feel this is the way they're going
to try and win and that's not the way it
goes that it'll be bedum in the country
it's a very bad thing it's a very bad
precedent as we said it's the opening of
a
Pandora that is all just true right like
that is just true if you start jailing
your political opponents if you create
all of these uneven uses of the court
system right oh that President
Declassified this this ex-president
Declassified that we're only going to go
after the Republicans we're going to
remove them from bance we can all see
that and and again ironically you know
it's funny because in some respects what
the the idea of the border and calling
everyone racist and all that that as I
said that was the rocket fuel the first
time they're going to use that again
this time but they've given him extra
Rocket Fuel this time because with all
of these selective court cases and going
after him and removing him from Bots
they're adding more rocket fuel it's
like if they would just stop doing all
of this nonsense he wouldn't have the
rocket fuel but they're giving him
Rocket Fuel and whether you like it or
not he has that Rocket Fuel it is just
true and then of course the other thing
is that they are intentionally trying to
destroy this country so all he has to
get up there and say is hey I'd prefer
not to destroy the country like for
example the Border Invasion that Jake
Tapper didn't want him to talk about
last night well here's just more video
of it real
quick so yes that is an invasion and it
is happening every day and it is not
anti-immigrant to say that those guys
who all look like they're about 25 to 35
years old fairly well-dressed no women
no kids no old people no huddled masses
it is not anti-immigrant to say sorry
you can't come but this is again they've
given us this they just frame things
every Every Which wrong way now of
course the other part of this is that as
I often say the Republicans basically
suck too we showed you this yesterday
this is the Schumer Lanford border deal
that is up in the Senate right now so
it's bipartisan and here are just a
couple of the bullet points on it
increased cards by 50,000 a year work
permits for adult children of H1B
holders immediate work permits to every
elal alien released from custody that's
basically everybody taxpayer funded
lawyers to certain uac's and mentally
incompetent
aliens like a mentally incompetent alien
is going to show up and get a government
lawyer like what 5,000 migrants per day
allowed into the US restricts parole for
those who enter without authorization
between ports of Entry so you get it
like it's not just the Democrats that
suck the Republicans suck too and that
again is another thing that has added
Rocket Fuel if the Republicans were if
the base of the Republicans were pretty
good then Trump wouldn't have this need
to be this Insurgent blasting through
the Republican party it's why I always
say I'm a Florida Republican but I'm not
a national Republican and then of course
there's the economy we've got some info
here from the Heritage Foundation uh
Americans are feeling the pain at the
pump and at the gross store inflation is
at a 40-year record high yet President
Joe Biden and his administration say the
economy is better than ever inflation
rates hit a 40-year high last week
coming in at
99.1% the cost of everyday Staples is
also increased the price of eggs went up
33% meat 8.2% gasoline 60% used cars 7%
and air travel
34% this is all in addition to supply
shortages yet as the economy is flashing
huge red warning signs President Joe
Biden and his administration are telling
us something
different okay so you get it there are
some problems again I barely need to
read those numbers to you because you go
to the store you see what's happening
you go get gas you know what's going on
and then of course the other piece of
all of this is that it does feel like
the world is in a very precarious spot
when it comes to foreign policy right
now there is a war there's a Ukraine
Russia war that we don't really talk
about anymore who knows what's going on
with that uh there is a war in the
Middle East that absolutely could turn
into something much wider and some more
stuff happened with Iran and Iraq
yesterday um so now let's flash back for
a moment to uh when Donald Trump was or
well this is this is Jared Kushner who
obviously Donald Trump's son-in-law but
was one of the key advisers of the Trump
Administration uh and here he is uh
talking about the difference between the
Trump administration's foreign policy
and what we're getting right now out of
the Biden Administration I would love to
ask you about leadership especially on
the on the side of the United States
what has um the current Administration
the Biden Administration done different
than the Trump Administration as you
understand uh that may have contributed
to the events we saw this week the Biden
Administration came in uh number one uh
they they they they started insulting uh
you know Saudi and Russia oil prices
went up at the same time what they did
was they stopped domestic production of
oil uh they made it they disincentivized
a lot of oil and shale
uh uh production uh with regulations
they they stopped pipelines oil prices
went up um they stopped enforcing the
sanctions against Iran probably to get
the oil prices lower to make up for what
they were doing they ran to Iran to try
to make a deal uh they started funding
the Palestinians again right away uh and
then overall just projecting a lot of
weakness uh in the region so uh one of
the the most um embarrassing examples is
what happened in the United Arab
Emirates again an amazing probably one
of America's best allies uh over for the
last you know 20 30 years uh they have
Rockets shot into their country uh from
from from uh from uh from from the
houthis and they basically don't get a
call from the US for 17 days they need
their equipment that they buy from the
US which creates job in the US they need
it restocked we don't call so they've
severely degraded the trust that we had
to rebuild with our okay that's Jared
Kushner who was one of the key
architects of the Abraham Accords uh
peace in the Middle East which is what
we were attaining which is that feels
like a lifetime ago it was it was two
and a half it was you know basically
three years ago and now it's as far gone
as it possibly could be the Middle East
is basically in in in the worst place
it's been in the last hundred years um
that's what's happening right now under
this Biden Administration and Jared lays
out uh many reasons for that right uh
then of course there's Ukraine we don't
know what the hell is going on there
anymore but now I just want to take you
back to a couple of the other things
that have happened since Joe Biden has
been president now we you know when
Donald Trump was President the Democrats
unleashed the base on the streets and we
had our summer of love and there were
violence in you know in the name of
diversity and inclusion we were burning
down mom and pop stores and everything
else well it is back now and this time
it is back instead instead of under the
BLM antifa Banner it is now back at with
these Pro Hamas rallies we didn't even
show you this clip yesterday but over
the weekend there was a crazy
group of people outside the White House
trying to break down the fence at the
white house riers uh I don't think
anyone was arrested or maybe one guy was
arrested uh and it's all coming back
right now this is the Democrat base but
they're even going after the Democrat
Administration right
[Applause]
[Music]
now break
it
[Applause]
support how
dare that's happening right now and the
question is for Donald Trump and I'll
get a little to this a little bit more
at the end will Donald Trump treat those
people a little bit differently than the
Biden Administration does or that blue
City Mayors are treating them which
they're treating them with complete
impunity right just do whatever the hell
you want rck things pull down monuments
spray paint all over stuff literally at
the gates of the White House they're
doing that nobody was arrested that's
what's happening under this
Administration there is a constant test
of what our society will will is willing
to take and we seem to be willing to
take a lot of uh but what else has
happened okay so you've got the violence
on the streets that's starting up again
we can see that it's it's just very
clear they can close Bridges whenever
they want they can block they can March
literally yesterday the pramas people in
New York City were marching outside of
the SLO ketering Cancer Institute and
shouting can you imagine you're you're
trying to recover from cancer and you
have a bunch of terrorist supporters
outside like it's just completely insane
but that's fully back well what else has
happened in these last two years we've
seen the complete collapse of our
education institutions the the Pinnacle
of that being this absolutely absurd
story where three ivy league College uh
presidents refused to condemn
anti-Semitism on their campus you may
remember this one from a couple weeks
ago uh Claude Dean gay now the
ex-president of Harvard do you believe
that type of hateful speech is contrary
to Harvard's code of conduct or is it
allowed at Harvard it is at odds with
the values of Harvard can you not say
here that it is against the code of
conduct at
Harvard we Embrace a commitment to free
expression even of views that are
objectionable offensive hateful it's
when that speech crosses into conduct
that violates our policies against
bullying harass does that speech not
cross that barrier does that speech not
call for the genocide of Jews and the
elimination of
Israel okay you know the outcome of that
because of the plagiarism Scandal not
because of the genocide thing she is no
longer the president of Harvard and on
MSNBC and everywhere else they're saying
it's because she's a black woman but
okay fine so I'm trying to connect all
of the things that we are now fighting
against you want Law and Order on the
streets you want want a border you want
to stop these these marxists from
controlling the minds of college
students what else might you want to do
you might want to actually stop them a
little bit earlier than College check
out this clip on The View yesterday was
it last week last week I said you know
my mom always says to me she always says
David you know when you're talking about
the view that you always call Sarah
Haynes you never say her name you always
say her she's the she's the blonde lady
uh so I tried to give her a little
credit I said her name but listen to
this abject nonsense from the blonde
lady I mean Sarah Haynes or whatever I
think there's there's more to it than
that look I think what it is is that um
black history and other things Banning
books has been weaponized for political
purposes to drive people to the polls
based on outrage because my poor little
white kid is feeling bad because he's
learning about slavery that's ridiculous
learning about history should not make
anybody feel bad we learn about history
should make you feel bad no important
that it makes you feel bad Hanah Naro is
just disgusting right because if your
child is being taught that they are bad
because they are white uh yeah you
should have sympathy for them and you
should get them out of that school but
then Sarah Haynes right there at the end
history should make you feel bad no it
shouldn't No it should not it doesn't
mean that history is perfectly clean it
doesn't mean that the founding of this
country is perfectly clean it doesn't
mean that slavery and everything is
perfectly clean but you can give an
honest assessment without making kids
feel bad about who they are these but
again I'm trying to show you how all of
the bad ideas of the left have have just
leaked into every institution cultural
institutions our TV networks our news
we're not going to we're not going to
show you Donald Trump he says mean
things we'll decide what you need to
know and then of course the next level
of all of this is how it has also leaked
into Tech and our algorithms literally
the way you are able to see this video
is if Google if you're watching on
YouTube right now although I hope you're
watching on rumble or locals if you're
watching on YouTube right now there is
an algorithm that decides whether you're
subscribed to this show or not whether
you're going to be put into the feed on
any given day and see my show what what
is next to it on suggested videos and if
they if they want you to oh you're
watching Dave Rubin we think you're
thinking a little too much like Dave
Rubin we can get you to think a whole
bunch of other things by clicking here
and you go well all right that's what
the algorithm does except the issue is
that the algorithm and Google's entire
Google which is the most powerful
company in the history of the world is
now has now fully embraced diversity
equity and inclusion check this video
out this is Google's Dei workplace
training program it's called racism
white people's role and
responsibility if you had been taught
equality from the beginning you wouldn't
be flipping out but that's how hegemonic
dominance works and so I think that's
why it happens and we have to be willing
to talk about that because it's really
unhealthy this white anxiety is a Public
Health crisis in that regard and that's
why you know not only we were talking in
the other room a minute ago before we
came in here you know that that it's not
just the opioid crisis that we think
about with folks killing themselves
disproportionately increasingly white
working-class folks who are um you know
using heroin or using over-the-counter
uh opioids um but they're political
opioids turning to a candidate who says
you vote for me and I will take away
your pain I will bring back those jobs I
will make your life better that's a form
of an opiate as well okay so what's the
point of showing you all of this on the
day after the Iowa caucus when I should
be talking about hardcore Politics the
point is that all of these cultural
issues are the things that lead to
certain candidates right they are as
I've said repeatedly now the rocket fuel
the way the media behaves calling
everyone racist you're white kids we
don't care about them all of that stuff
is what led to the ground swell of
support for Donald Trump the the poit
politicization of our courts so that we
go after political opponents that is
what led to Donald Trump and everything
else and what it also leads to when all
of see all this stuff all of the time
and we see people rampaging through our
borders and we see prices rising it
leads to a demoralization right so that
you start walking around and you start
thinking maybe this country isn't that
great and you start thinking ah maybe we
shouldn't have Law and Order and oh
there's just trash on the street and
nothing really works and that's kind and
you know you should be able to attack
the White House if your cause is just or
whatever so Biden and the Democrats have
ushered in three years of political and
cultural rot it's not only on the
Democrats but this country is on its way
to becoming unrecognizable that's what
demoralization over years and years does
now I want to show you a video you
remember this guy this is Yuri benov a
former KGB agent explaining exactly how
you could demoralize a public uh if you
so wanted to dropouts or half-baked
intellectuals are now occupying the
positions of power in the government
civil service business mass media
educational system you are stuck with
them they are contaminated they are
programmed to think and react to certain
stimuli in a certain pattern you cannot
change their mind even if you if you
expose them to authentic information a
person who was
demoralized is unable to assess true
information the facts tell nothing to
him uh even if I shower him with
information with with authentic proof
with documents with pictures he will
refuse to believe it until he he's going
to receive a kick in the in his fat
bottom when a military boot crashes his
bows then he will okay so we have been
infected at virtually every level and
then enough people start seeing that and
then what does that lead us to it leads
us to potentially what looks like the
return of Donald Trump so now what is
the challenge for anyone that isn't just
uh worshiping of trump that realizes he
is just a man and he is flawed and he
made mistakes and he still does his
loose lies and all of that stuff well I
think there is something that we can do
right now so again if you are the
biggest as Santa supporter if you if you
absolutely hate Trump but you hate the
Democrats a little bit more there is
something that you can do right now uh
and it's it's actually being moral and
using honesty and integrity and and and
fighting for truth and thus holding
Donald Trump to a higher standard I
think that will be the mission for me
for the next year is not just be like
all right I'm just back on the Trump
train and let's just do this thing it's
going to be all right Trump you want
four more years well then you're going
to have to damn well be better than you
were last time so let's go into a couple
of the mistakes the guy made so that we
are armed and and we can then push him
to be a little bit better uh as you know
Trump did lock down the country and he
lied about it and fouchy and whatever so
let's revisit some of that would you
ever allow a shutdown in the future
talking about a covid shutdown correct
no I wouldn't and I never did we did the
right thing we Clos the country down I
could have kept it open and I could have
done what some countries are doing I had
to shut it down we did the right thing
Florida did shut down run to sanct is
shut down we're in a place called
Florida and we have a great governor
great governor knows exactly what he's
doing terrific job he just announced
that the schools will be open Governor
has done a great job Florida is down low
now in the China virus he shut his State
down very violently and you're open and
you didn't close and you're it's just
amazing right it's great one of the
greatest governors in our country and I
know a lot of good ones and I can tell
you there's some really bad ones too but
this is a great one Governor Ronda Sant
all right so I want Trump to be better
than that right I don't want him to to
spit in our face and tell us it's
Sunshine that's not a phrase is it you
get it we can push him to be better than
that right because he knew he was lying
about all that stuff and I'll Grant you
that's primary politics and I guess he
did it the best it is what it is but the
other thing he was also lying about
constantly it was somehow that Ron de
santis had a lot he was a Paul Ryan
accolate right he was Paul Ryan was his
master and he was coordinating with Jeb
Bush and Paul Ryan of course it was a
complete lie you might remember this
tweet from Donald Trump Don I'm working
I'm working today to make you a little
bit better this is Donald Trump and
speaker Paul Ryan is truly a good man
and while he will not be seeking
reelection he will leave a legacy of
achievement that nobody can question we
are with you Paul so okay that's a
mistake by Donald Trump right Mistake by
Donald Trump another mistake by Donald
Trump and again guys I know now if
you're Trump people you might be annoyed
at me again right some disantis people
might might be annoying me Dave you're
you're you're he hasn't conceded now
some Trump people you stop talking about
all the bad things that Trump did but no
it's the only way he is going to be
better and he screwed up an awful lot of
things like constantly hiring people
from the swamp and then turning on them
and everything else so don you can't do
this whole thing again from 2017 to
2020 understands that the job of
Attorney General is to Serve and Protect
the people of the United States and that
is exactly what he will do and do better
than anybody else can Jeff sessions was
a disaster as attorney general should
have never been attorney general he's
not qualified he's not mentally
qualified to be attorney general we hope
Bill bar is going to be as good as we
think because Bill is a good he is a
great gentleman a great man and by the
way when Bill bar who's you know a
coward Bill bar was a coward Bill bar
didn't do what he was supposed to do I
fired him and he has great hatred in his
new role as chairman of the Joint Chiefs
of Staff General Millie will serve as my
top military advisor I have absolute
confidence that he will fulfill his duty
with the same Brilliance and fortitude
he has shown throughout his long and
very distinguished career Millie
frankley was incompetent the last one
I'd want to attack with as my leader
would be Millie John Kelly will do a
fantastic job General Kelly has been a
star done an incredible job thus far
respected by by everybody a great great
American I know John Kelly he was with
me didn't do a good job had no
temperament and ultimately he was
petered out he got he was exhausted this
man was totally exhausted he wasn't even
able to function I am confident that Jay
has the wisdom and Leadership to guide
our economy through any challenges that
our great economy May face and you know
I had my own situation with Powell and I
beat the hell out of him I was not a big
fan of pal I was he was recommended by
some people I didn't like okay so
there's a couple things here it's like
he was definitely a better president
than Joe Biden is he a artist
and a con man and all of that stuff yes
yes he is but he is also at this point I
think it's fair to say he's basically
the presumptive nominee so we can either
push him to now be a little bit better
we can push him to maybe be a little
more honest we can push him to be a
little bit of a better version of
himself and and we can hold him to a
higher standard or we can just worship
Him and the whole damn thing all of the
things that got wrong all of the wrong
hes right there and the idiots and the
morons who were the best of the best
before they will all be ushered back in
and then everything will be worse four
years from now right so that is the
challenge the only way that we can beat
Evil and there is a lot of evil out
there is is by being good right truth is
the thing that is going to set us three
set us free so not just worshiping and
not just being no matter what he says
we're just going to love it right we're
just going to bow to him all the time
not just being compassionate all the
time we are going to have to actually
stand up straight with our shoulders
back get a backbone like a ramrod and
and actually do something true Jordan
Peterson ladies and gentlemen so you
don't think that that came from a place
of compassion I don't care if comp I
don't regard compassion as a virtue
compassion is a reflex not a virtue you
don't think judicious compassion is a
virtue wait wait a minute wait a minute
compassion can come deep
from the human heart and the human mind
I think are we talking about the same
kind of compassion trying to understand
the suffering treating adults like
infants is not virtuous I I see but you
you well compassion isn't treating
adults like in I mean those are just
terms are you sure okay I whatever the
term is maybe love is compassion is I
mean I suppose I'm speaking to love you
don't think those ideas came from
concern compassion
you don't think love is a blend of
compassion and encouragement and Truth
Love's complicated man if if I love you
is it Compassion or encouragement you
want from me yeah it's a dance love love
is definitely a dance of two two humans
ultimately that leads to the growth of
both well that's the thing the growth
element is crucial yeah because the
growth element to Foster the growth
element that requires
judgment compassion and judgment
well even and have been conceptualized
this way forever two hands of God mercy
and Justice they have to operate in
tandem right and mercy
is flawed as you are you're
acceptable it's like well do you want
that do you want your flaws to be
acceptable and the answer to that is no
it's so it's like well that's where the
Judgment comes in it's like but you
could be better you could be more than
you are and that is exactly what we need
from Trump right now Trump will not get
better by worshiping him if we all just
oh my God he did it again let's get on
the Trump train let's destroy everybody
and that will not make any of this
better you know what will make some of
this better how about compassion right
with a little judgment and how about
some truth wouldn't that be something if
we pushed him that way that might be
something and then we could get out of
this and I actually think he has it in
him I think he knows how to fight and
sometimes what I would argue is
absolutely disgusting manner right the
things he has said about Dan santis and
the lies about Florida the place that he
and his entire family live and all of
that stuff absolutely disgusting the way
he manipulated people millions of people
who now hate Ronda santis who who knew
he was the best governor governor in
America a year ago right so there's all
the disuss stuff there but with a little
compassion a little judgment and a
little truth I know that Donald Trump
can be better because he's a little
closer to something honest and real than
anyone on the other side and he does
have some of those inklings you might
remember this from a week ago his town
hall a lot of time talking about
retribution and so there are questions
about how much a second term of a Donald
Trump presidency second term would be
about
retribution and looking backwards and
Grievances and how much would be looking
forward well first of all a lot of
people would say that that's not so bad
look what they did Russia Russia Russia
hoax the FBI Twitter hoax the 51
intelligence agents hoax all of these
different hoaxes that they did I mean
you know a lot of people would say
that's probably quite normal I'm not
going to have time for Retribution we're
going to make this country so successful
again I'm not going to have time for
retri that's it right there right don't
run now on retribution and I'm going to
jail everybody and I'm angry at
everybody and everything else right it
looks like you're going to get this
nomination fairly easily there's the
court cases and everything else but
success is ultimate winner here right
success for the country is the
retribution which I understand why you
might want a little bit of Retribution
but I now think it is on us to build
Trump up so that he can be the best
version of himself as opposed to the
golden calf version of himself that many
people want to worship so we don't need
to feed the delusion we actually just
have to angle ourselves a little bit
more to truth I actually think we can
offer him a little bit of help maybe
he's in a ditch right the world rolls up
against him he's in a ditch maybe we can
offer him a couple shovel fulls of uh of
soil have I told you guys the story of
the donkey and the well take a
[Music]
listen
for
so that is Malay stronger what does he
say stronger and higher than ever before
as he gets out of that ditch that's what
that's what Donald Trump could be that's
what he could be there's all the
frustrations that I have with him this
thing as far as I can tell at the moment
did not go the way that I think would be
best I think I actually think I think in
my heart of hearts there was a better
way okay it is what it is here we are I
see the world as it is not as I wish it
to be so truth is the truth is the soil
you are the shovel use it people in the
internet is live at 1M Ruben report.
locals.com postgame show in 30 seconds
we leave you with a cold close of the
guy that I'm not going to vote for being
creepy back in 2014
goodbye Vice President Biden moving in
close to sell the Affordable Care Act to
a young woman outside Butterfields
Pancake House in Scottdale everybody
young signs up for healthcare it's
affordable you can get subsidies to do
it and it's in your interest and if you
don't even want to do it for yourself do
it for your parents give them Peace of
Mind turns out that woman is not even a
US resident she's visiting from Canada I
just didn't know if I
should just say I'm
sorry
[Music]